Mì bá thức bệnh công man tình từ quan trò biết, linh quan đến vụ án lệ giúp chức vụ quyền hạ trong khi thì hành công vụ,
sây ra tại điểm thì chương trường hoặc của thông truyền tuân quan, trong khi thì tốt nghiệp Trung hoặc của thông năm 2020,
các quan nhiều trà công man tình từng quan vừa tiếp tục khởi tố thêm mới lắm bị cá,
cùng vì tội lợi giúp chức vụ quyền hạ trong khi thì hành công vụ quy định tại bộ lợi thình xưa và áp giúp các miệnh pháp ngâm trạng theo quy định của pháp lợi.
Như vậy đến nay thì các quan đều tra công man tình từng quan đã khởi tố mời chính bị cá trong vụ án để vụ vụ công tất nhiều tra.
Khi thì tốt nghiệp Trung hoặc của thông năm 2020, trong tình từng quan cũng mới tấm nghiệp 2,5 tạm tình xin.
Đàn kỹ giúp thi, trong lỏ thì mời bệnh nghiệp không chăm mời bệp tình xin đăng học lớp 12 và mừng kỹ 2,5 tình xin tự giò.
Theo kết quả ra xoà xưa bộ tại điểm thì chương trường hoặc của thông truyền tuân quan,
có hóa 3,5 tình xin đăng kỹ giúp thi một toán trong lỏ thì 3,5 tình xin giúp thi,
và phản một. Theo giúp liệu đã tốt bộ thì trong tầm số 8,5 tạm học sinh của chiều nữ thi,
có 2,5 tình xin đăng tự giữ chiến đeệm cho lên 1 toán,
trong bỏ 1,5 tình xin đăng kỹ mời đêm chút mấy mỗi toán của toán chiều đã chiến phẩy nằm bị tấm.
Trời nừng giấu hiệu bất thường bộ giáo dụng vào đoạn thịt lập tổ cũng tác vụng đại diện
các nình địa chức năng của bộ của bộ công an để kiếm tra xác mình tại hỗ đồng tì.